an ore that could save or end the world
and the rise of a new dark lord the
ending of the Rings of power season one
will change the future of Middle Earth
forever
fans of The Lord of the Rings know Kaza
Doom as the Sinister Moria and the Lord
of the Rings the rings of power though
those dark days haven't yet arrived
instead bands are introduced to a
magnificent Subterranean Kingdom at the
Zenith of its Glory as season one plays
out the primary Dwarven plot lines form
around King Duran III his son Prince
Duren IV and during the fourth's wife
princess disa tensions rise as Prince
Duren discovers mithro in an abandoned
mine it turns out that the elves need
this Ultra precious metal to prevent
their Spirits from fading the king
refuses to help his allies for fear of
Darker repercussions from the land's
many secret dangers delving into debts
Beyond The Darkness tempting Shadow Rock
and Main
30 years old beneath the mountain but
his son wants to help the elves
especially his friend elrond the two
remain in Conflict which causes a rift
in the family and the elimination of
Prince duren's claim to the throne in
our last moments in kazad Doom we see
the angry hurt king throw a rejuvenated
Leaf into the mithril vein before they
close up the mine it floats far into the
shaft landing near a lurking balrog when
it finally reaches the floor that's the
last we see of the fiery demon but it
leaves a plethora of questions about the
future of the Dwarven City
the elves are strong in the second age
in fact they are the primary power when
the rings of power starts and their
greatest stronghold is Linden situated
in the northwest region of Middle Earth
Linden is ruled by High King gilgolland
despite his strength all is not well in
the Magical Kingdom the elves are fading
and must find a way to rejuvenate
themselves in the light of valinor lest
they be forced to leave their home on
Middle Earth this leads to an ongoing
struggle as gilgolett schemes with
Keller brimbor Lord of distant irregion
to find a solution to their dilemma
eventually an apocryphal tale about
mithril is brought up and they
manipulate elrond into trying to recover
some of the miracle metal from the
dwarves in the end Lenten is spared its
Doom as the three Elven rings are forged
in time using the small sample of
mithril given to elrond as a gift to
keep the elves in Middle Earth it's a
good thing too the Elvish Kingdom will
provide a lot of the muscle in the
coming Wars with Sauron
throughout season one the Elvish
territory of Aragon located near the
Western entrance to kazadum is little
more than a footnote to the story
we see a couple of meetings between
elrond and kellebrimbor and a few shots
of a giant Forge being built it isn't
until The Season's end that the region
steals the Limelight specifically its
capital city of Austin ethyl which means
Fortress of the Eldar The Elms of
iregion are famous Smiths and their
leader Keller brimbor is hell-bent on
finding a magical way to stop the blight
afflicting his people
while it doesn't have a ton of screen
time in season one a Region's role in
the second age is difficult to
understate
the final episode of the Season depicts
the forging of three of the Rings of
power within its walls though the rest
of the magical jewelry remains
conspicuously missing Keller brimbora's
people are also famous in tolkien's
writings for forging a close-knit
friendship with the dwarves of Kaza Doom
their leader is even a key contributor
to the famous doors that open at the
word friend what does fate have in store
for the Elven Citadel plenty but we
don't know exactly how it'll play out
the Proto Hobbit harfoots receive a
significant amount of attention
throughout season one from their quiet
hidden lives to their Rough and Tumble
cultural quirks they provide a
fascinating look into a much larger
story and that tale literally crashes
into their midst in the form of a wizard
cryptically referred to as the stranger
this Supernatural visitor shakes up the
Harford Community starting with The
Adventurous Nori and Poppy after making
initial contact these two harfoots help
guide the confused starfallen figure
they bring him along on their migration
until his usefulness as a protector and
his inherent goodness went over the rest
of their group including their leader
static in the end sadik poppy Nori and
Marigold help the stranger overcome a
trio of evil Mystics who emerge from
roon though the Invaders are defeated
static loses his life in the scuffle
leaving a leadership Gap that the
orphaned poppy seems red Phil Nori Parts
ways with her people in the finale
joining her friend as he sets off to
search for answers I turn around
I won't ever be able to leave
well then
perhaps it would be best if you lead off
tolkien's island nation of numenor is
one of the most famous locations of the
second age when Galadriel and halbrand
later revealed to be Sauron arrive on
its Shores they find a nation of men who
like the dwarves of Kaza Doom are at the
peak of their glory and yet all is not
well on the star-shaped Island as the
season continues we discovered that the
King tarpalantir has been pushed from
Power due to his pro-elvish beliefs his
daughter Muriel rules in his stead and
struggles to keep the peace between the
traditional faithful and the progressive
King's Men for his own Chancellor and
cousin to the queen regent clearly
Harbors anti-elvish sentiment Fierce
death and is scheming to exploit
resource-rich Middle Earth even the
minor Noble line of elendil is hurting
with the Future King and his family
mourning the loss of their matriarch
when the Story begins everywhere they
turn the new minority ends are
struggling even when they sail to Middle
Earth to help the southlanders they walk
into a volcanic catastrophe and hightail
it back to numenor to regroup the
question is how will this slowly
crumbling Nation overcome its latent
flaws as time goes on especially with
Sauron aware of its jaw-dropping
potential
in The Lord of the Rings Mordor is a
nearly impenetrable hellscape the dark
lord has called home for centuries but
in The Lord of the Rings the rings of
power the realm doesn't exist yet early
in the season it slowly revealed that a
group of Orcs led by a twisted elf
called Adar is creeping into an area
known as the Southlands things look
dicey but the real danger doesn't reveal
itself until the end of episode 6 when
Mount Doom is unleashed the entire area
is turned into a fiery heap of volcanic
ash instantly creating Mordor the
establishment of Mordor is a big deal in
the source material this event provides
Sauron with a home base where he can
plot scheme and gather his armies though
Mordor is created in the rings of power
it isn't sauron's home base yet but the
last thing we see is the newly revealed
Sauron heading into the area there's a
lot more to come as the power struggle
shakes out in the land of Shadow
the South Landers Homeland is destroyed
halfway through season one of the Rings
of power before that point they're
established as a tough group of men
contending with a combination of their
own past sins and the elves Perpetual
power when Adar and the Orcs show up the
South Landers are forced to choose
between good and evil many of them
quickly return to their old ways but the
rest resist led by Town healer Bronwyn
and her Elvish bow a rundier thanks to
some timely aid from numenor they win
the initial fight only to see their
lands devastated by Mount Doom
ultimately the southlanders make their
way out of newly minted Mordor and head
for Pilar gear in the source material
this numenorian colony is a key city of
the faithful and a crucial urban center
of future Gondor this could bode well
for the South Landers headed that way as
the season ends however it remains to be
seen if this settlement will the same
geopolitical weight in the rings of
power
Hal brand one of the characters fans
suspected was Sauron ends up unmasking
himself as the dark lord just before
season one's credits roll until this
point he masquerades around Middle Earth
under the guise of a dispossessed
southern King called halbrand in that
Persona he saves Galadriel at Sea only
to be talked into reclaiming his kingdom
by the elf Warrior after a lot of
heroics halbrand gives Keller brimbor
some very specific and suspicious
smithing advice this is the kind of
insight that a lowly mortal human should
never be able to casually offer the
world's greatest living Craftsman after
nudging the Smith of the region into
creating some circular jewelry
halbrand's disguise is revealed thanks
to galadriel's investigative work this
leads to a confrontation in which Sauron
reveals who he is walks Galadriel
through a semi-convincing vision and
even makes her attempting offer you
would make me a tyrant
I would make you a queen
this disconcerting offer is thankfully
rejected by Galadriel finished
manipulating the elves for the time
being Sauron makes a run for it and
heads to Mordor we see him entering the
land of Shadow with this cape billowing
behind him and a Sly grin on his face
before season one Fades to Black
Sauron has a long upward trajectory
throughout the second age before he's
brought to ruin by the events many know
from the opening sequence of Peter
Jackson's The Lord of the Rings The
Fellowship of the Ring after that Sauron
takes a new shave spend some time as the
Necromancer and eventually becomes the
titular threat of The Lord of the Rings
but most of his narrative as middle
Earth's villainous primeval is still in
front of him as season one of the Rings
of power plays out over the course of
Eight Episodes we see how Bran's
complicated haphazard trajectory slowly
turned into sauron's master plan there
is a whole lot more to come while
discussing what season 2 will bring with
GQ sauron's actor Charlie Vickers said
we start to see sauron's journey in the
same way that we saw galadriel's Origins
we see it for Sauron now he's out there
and the game is a foot for him so we get
to start to see him manipulating People
sauron's season 1 reveal may be a Slow
Burn but now that he's out in the open
we can expect some true fireworks
season one of the Rings of power is
filled with character development stage
setting Exposition and by the time the
finale rolls around some initial answers
but it still manages to leave a lot of
nagging questions behind while he's
officially established as a wizard the
stranger's identity remains shrouded in
mystery Galadriel casually mentions that
she lost her husband kelleborn in a war
centuries earlier a significant break
from tolkien's work firizone is clearly
plotting to abuse numenora's position as
middle Earth's Savior and is showing
some blatant fears about his impending
doom elendo's daughter Aryan looks into
a palantir a sealdor goes M.I.A amidst
the action in Mordor there's even a
balrock that wakes up in the depths of
the dwarves domain while a lot of
initial plot threads are addressed in
the finale there's no doubt that more
questions are left hanging than answered
while this might seem frustrating this
Myriad of mysteries gives viewers Food
For Thoughts and ammunition for analysis
for a long time to come
as season one comes to a close the three
Elven rings are forged but that's not
the end of the story for the Rings
tolkien's rings of power include nine
rings for Mortal men seven for the dwarf
Lords and one ring to rule them all that
leaves 17 more rings of power to be made
or at least revealed in the series the
creation of the One Ring clearly lies in
sauron's future but we have no idea
where the rest of the Rings are in the
source material they're created by
Sauron and Keller brimbor who doesn't
know he's working with the dark lord
before the three Elven rings are forged
this means we're left with three paths
either the other Rings already exist in
the TV series world they're going to be
foraged at a later date or they won't be
made at all whatever the answer to this
question the one thing that's certain is
that we're going to need to wait for
season two to learn the fate of the
Rings of power
[Music]